oh hi I'm Finn wolfhard
I'm dove Cameron I'm KJ Appa I'm Millie
Bobby Brown I am Jessica Chastain I am
Sophie Tana hi I'm Athena and I'm
nourish nap and we're going to be doing
the Y or the autocomplete interview odor
outer eye
[Music]
what daniel radcliffe is what what is
Daniel what is daniel radcliffe this is
a complicated question directly this is
mostly water and carbon what do you
think the first one was gonna say is
Mindy Kaling a human being is Mindy
Kaling real I was right I went they
think I'm a I just she's been a hologram
this whole time did Jack Black sing
welcome to the jungle in Jumanji no I
didn't but I sang it on the set of
Jumanji a lot a lot this fall apart
seeing it take on me today did Colin
Farrell auditioned for boys onward yeah
boys own and I was tone-deaf I signed
Careless Whisper twice in a room for the
producers I think that got me down asked
me to sing it the second time because I
was so tone deaf the first time they
couldn't actually believe I had the
balls to stand in front of them and say
okay so it was a boy band spider-man we
sell Danna in Avengers end game I don't
know I got a check for it so well wait
is that a movie that's already come out
I know it's gonna come out soon and you
don't know if you're in it no oh I was
asked to I was asked to say I don't know
how a Captain Marvel gets her powers can
I say
no.1 for Marvel's here okay great
Captain Marvel gets her powers from a
crazy blast does Anthony Mackie like Tom
Holland you know what I actually do Tom
Holland is my friend that's why I make
fun of him I love the kid he's a great
great kid he's the best bite of man
we've had but he's an arrogant little
it's safe
I'm wearing a wig right now yes I'm
wearing a full wig American American and
merkins for the armpits to mark in is I
should wake you going pitch his Pedro
Pascal death why don't you answer that
he's certainly Oscar would say that I
was I die a lot I think that's why they
ask that it's cuz I know you don't you
famously die get killed off a lot yeah
but you just do it so well my head
squished thrown off Towers kill them
Google could Jaime Lannister be a
Targaryen you know it's Game of Thrones
anything's possible
where is Jon Hamm in Game of Thrones
hired everybody in Europe for that job
nicholas hoult in Game of Thrones I am
I'm very good in it great acting are you
in Game of Thrones I love to be though I
got halfway through Game of Thrones I
just cut I couldn't keep up and when Ned
Stark died I was like why am I even
watching this anymore like I can't deal
what does Ned Stark whispered before he
dies Gangnam style
yeah no I wasn't it was a little prayer
Sarah Paulsen does Drew Barrymore
impression
yes she does I think I've seen it thank
you so much thank you I can do this
Smeagol voice gone from The Lord of the
Rings Ron Howard's daughter no I'm not
nope you do look like Bryce Dallas
Howard I do we look alike I which I love
what links Daniel Radcliffe and Viggo
Mortensen does this person think I'm
Elijah Wood lieutenant replied oh man I
wanna take this one Wow God what he does
you know why Time Lords they got all the
time in the hands yeah is Emma Thompson
in Star Wars no no
if Emma Thompson was in Star Wars as do
you know when the young Jedi has lost
their will to live and they end up in a
forest somewhere and then someone
appears to them to teach them yes you
would be great at that yes or I could be
Jabba the Hutt's handmade okay thatís
easy one it would be fun and you would
like to wear that bikini I could squeeze
those frogs for you no supposed to be
ooh good tossing Wolverine thanks man
yeah Hugh Jackman yeah are you yeah were
you supposed to be Hugh Jackman it was
like toss up because of the ABS these
are my texts sorry sound man is Liam
Payne a daddy I am a daddy
I just don't know what to say about it
cuz I am a daddy yeah book in that way
am I gonna be yours
what does funder eat for breakfast
my boyfriend well toasted buttered on
both sides she doesn't have a boyfriend
shush I can fantasising France naturally
great actually let me feel this question
it would be impossible for him to have
salt and pepper bleach in tone that well
there's no way I can artificially make
something that can Bryce Dallas Howard
cry on command yeah no I can definitely
definitely definitely without question
any time you want me to I can Greg okay
miss Charles Moulton a dancer finally I
can dance I can dance that's all I got
right now
that's how I got jacked